this X by itself so what we're gonna do
is we're going to work from the outside
in by doing the opposite operation so
what I would do first is I would add 20
okay so working from the outside in
towards the backs I'm going to do the
opposite add 20 right so if I do that
that gives us 24 okay these are going to
cancel we've got 6x squared left right
now same thing we're multiplying by 6 we
want to do the opposite of multiplying
by 6 we want to divide both sides by 6
so we're narrowing down or getting
closer to that X 2 isolating it by
itself and then now we've got x squared
equals 4 we want to do the opposite of
squaring which is to take the square
root of both sides but remember when you
take the square root of both sides of
the equation you actually get two
answers plus or minus and the square
root of 4 is 2 so those are our
solutions positive or negative 2 okay
example B here it says 5 plus 3x squared
equals negative 10 same idea we want to
work from the outside in towards that X
get that X by itself so let's do the
opposite of adding 5 let's subtract 5
these cancel we get 3x squared is equal
to negative 15 we're gonna do the
opposite of multiplying by 3 we wanna
divide both sides by 3 so x squared
gives us negative 5 and we want to take
the square root because that's the
opposite of squaring both sides ah but
we have a problem here we can't take the
square root of a negative number that's
going to give us an imaginary number
which you usually get into when you get
into algebra 2 and precalculus so for
this one we're just gonna say that
there's no real solution okay it's an
imaginary solution so we'll just say no
real solution so when you take the
square root of a negative number
okay letter C now a little bit more
challenging here we've got 2 times the
quantity X minus 3 squared plus 4 equals
54 and again what you want to do is you
want to work from the outside in towards
that X right so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to subtract 4 that's the kind
of the farthest out so to speak okay
furthest away and so that's going to
cancel that's going to give us 50 and
then over here we have 2 times X minus 3
squared we want to then divide both
sides by 2 okay so you can see how we're
narrowing narrowing down getting closer
to this X then we want to say well
what's the opposite of squaring we want
a square root okay so we want to get rid
of that square there so square root so
that's going to be X minus 3 equals plus
or minus 5 now this is a lot of students
miss this point here because as soon
you take the square root that's when you
want to add that plus or minus sign
right and then the last step also a
little bit confusing for some students
you want to add three to both sides but
put that plus three in front over to the
left of that plus or minus sign that's
important the other way to do this
problem okay a lot of students will do
it this way I think this is a good
technique split this up into two
equations X minus 3 equals positive 5x
minus 3 equals negative 5 and then solve
those individually so you could add 3
that's going to give you 8 and if you
add 3 here that's going to give you
negative 2 but if you like this method
you just put that plus 3 in front so
that's going to be 3 plus or minus 5 3
plus 5 is 8 3 minus 5 is negative 2